I reject nation I'm Greg Alba what is
your name buff man I'm Norville - Floyd
Norville - Floyd you have a youtube
channel don't you I do
nan GC productions ghost n JC
productions
you said Neji Neji C productions and JC
productions all right JC productions
this guy is a filmmaker yo he actually
together a feature film trailer for
beyond the Sivas on YouTube you guys
should check it out it like horror
movies 80s themes horror movies to be
particular you should love it yeah check
I mean the trailer you won't get the
vibe of 80s all from the trailer we have
but when you see the out - movie it's a
tease that's great marketing oh yeah
we're gonna watch Dead Redemption -
launch trailer before we go into this I
have to get the patron of the day shadow
- a very special man named Tyler hey I
actually know Norville because he was
originally a patron and because he did
that he's welcome into my home now only
patrons are welcomed over here it's a
very great service you should try it
yeah you should try a shameful plug my
girlfriend can't be in my apartment so
she pledges I hope you're watching baby
it's Tyler who was Tyler actually this
is really kind gentleman from Wisconsin
he purchased a ps4 pro the bundle was
Red Dead Redemption - a pre-order and
it's being shipped to my apartment isn't
that the craziest [ __ ] in the world
Tyler I can't wait to go down on you
wait but aren't you an Xbox person
excuse me
no oh okay I was talking about going
down on Tyler you interrupted me with
this blasphemy okay just one sorry Tyler
it makes the gift that if you know
hardest to give these shoutouts
sometimes
I've tried giving you a shout-out you
see John enough to me with dumb things
like that Norville he kind of did yeah
he tends to be that way I'm gonna
finally have a ps4 all thanks to you
Tyler I will do an unboxing video I love
you buddy
you know how much I love you this guy's
just a jolly fellow who just brings a
big smile
oh man my best friend's name is Tyler
that's my way to way to link it
one more big score we got enough money
to lose what do you think
I wish thank you for definitely want us
to change trust me
Bertha just one
want to kill all these Dutch just
[Music]
[Music]
26 the game Joe Morrison it's probably
gonna be one of those like you played
like the main character that they have
right now a couple of hours in and
they'll have like that one side mission
what you play as John yeah no this main
character dies and then all of a sudden
you're starting to play the first great
Dead Redemption again I was slightly
concerned they weren't gonna get the
same voice actor back slightly because
yeah I can't emphasize this we had a
couple trailers in and I know he was
like he's in the game but we haven't
heard him speak within to hear his voice
again the Western accent it's like so
cool yeah in any way I'm sorry
you're a worth my money or likes things
like that you know I I like it I don't
know it's just good it came across in
the game you know anyways continue yeah
it's coming across there's something
about his delivery I've always loved
there's a weird tone to how he does it
John Marston it's always coming up here
and my sentence is every time he topics
yeah graphics are good too it's so much
better than the last one so much like
the first game is all about the gameplay
in the world and of course the only
thing that was missing for me in the
first game was better graphics which is
like a really hard thing to request for
a game that gives you that much to do
yeah that's so like way back in the
early ps3 era yeah but now with the ps4
Pro I can't wait to play this in 4k you
know that was a good HDR I can't wait to
land my 4k ps4 pro on my not 4k so
smoother playthrough it'll look like a
crispy er 1080p okay it'll perform
better you won't have so many glitches I
think this is like all the things my
girlfriend tells me I hear a couple the
keywords that sound sexual and I
[Music]
this feels more like the storyline I was
hoping I would hop into with Red Dead
Redemption 1 because I didn't know
anything about Red Dead Redemption
before I played it I was like I heard
it's the Western grant that thought I
went away I played it and it has all
that in the gameplay I wasn't the
biggest fan of the way the plot was
going first thing I like if I'm about to
get some haters for all this automatic
cuz I love the game the way the plot
unfolded I wasn't a huge fan of it when
they just betrayed them at the end
beyond that it's like like it's it's an
interesting setup but I wanted something
where what this games giving me you're
just out long you know and you got like
a sheriff who's out to get you like like
the like the real westerns I grew up on
this feels like the western movies I
used to watch and the gameplay is like
super expand upon one thing I don't like
about the gameplay and it's a bit picky
it's like the horse mechanic that they
have your horse can die ain't you got
gain trust with your horse in order for
him to do certain things your horse
could die and you got to get a new horse
anything you got to like rebuild your
trust with that horse I hate that
because I don't like it if like you have
like an animal they cry like a dog that
can die because that'll hit me
personally if your dog died in Fallout 4
how would you be sad I would be hurt if
my dog died in Fallout 4 I couldn't do
it that's why in New Vegas when you had
the option to take that dog he was
gaming you guy said no because I didn't
want to deal with the fact that he might
die if like a gun shoot I went wrong Wow
okay so now that the horse can die
that's my gripe about everything I think
you did the horse die in the first game
I don't remember it's been so long dude
I was going through horses left and
right super carefully my horses all know
what you doing is the point of immersion
and gameplay is to treat it as like real
life yeah try not to get your horse
killed I spent most of the time just
shooting the animals I didn't shoot
anything I just shot animal if you can't
tell I'm an animal lover so see my
girlfriend's a huge animal lover so it's
just fun to provoke her with I'm putting
together his animal death compilation
from movies
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
but going back to john marston really
quick away from animal deaths we were
talking about like how it was a joke
about if you like do like a random side
mission towards the end or your job John
yeah but I'm kind of thinking that
towards the end of this game cuz I
imagine there's gonna be hours and hours
of gameplay to come here that by the
time you get close to the end of the
story that they'll probably start
infusing John Marston Moor in here
because this is a prequel I hate it when
they call things part two but they're
pretty cool so good but because this is
a prequel I imagine they're gonna do
something that's more than just a cool
ending tie-in but maybe like the last
couple hours of the game or something
that's super hyper linked to what's
gonna come for that the leaks into the
tale of Red Dead Redemption one because
all the Red Dead Redemption one is you
know John Marcin has left the gang and
he wants to lead a normal life so maybe
you're gonna get that moment where he
meets his prostitute of a wife and all
those things
my Conor a horse she's just a prostitute
that was her backstory bust is a
profession it's a profess a profession
it's a profession alright that's a word
right Norville has to do things out in
Vegas sometimes to make money where he's
from
don't judge him yeah I know I know three
friends were strippers or not they're
not [ __ ] do they invite me to the
strip clubs that they work at no have I
ever been in a strip club before no it
has three stripper friends who you know
sorry don't give her some restrictions
and you never bothered to like go see
them at work I haven't no they're your
stripper friends I know that's the
that's the gripe about it why would you
not see your stripper friends at work
Adam maybe I haven't had that if you
knew a porn star would you not watch her
videos if I was dating a porn star or
vanilla painter no a porn star you know
what sweets are I feel guilty if she's
like my friend you know I can't watch
her I was like no that's weird you know
I'd never had a stripper friend or
wherever they don't have the ability to
play as John in this game I think a lot
of
would be mad you got to have at least
like a little at least more like like
how they last of us they had you play le
for that one hour I think I mean it
would be it would be pretty sweet I mean
I think if he could we did Red Dead
Redemption three and you picked up four
where John marcin's kid is right well no
one but yeah into the first whatever or
you could do something where if there
was one of those like cool endings kind
of like a paranormal activity to did by
the time you get to the end of this one
it like ties into continuation of John
Martins kid I forget his name Jack and
say you ties into that that would be
cool I don't think is gonna do any of
what I want but it's gonna be cool all
right guys right Dead Redemption - are
you excited to play I hope you are you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
and NJC productions I'm like I'll get
there have you ever heard the words no
well how's this Wow okay comedy people
take a class it's a comedy is subjective
depends you guys can click that
notification valve check out naejay car
how'd you say it earlier
much of what have you seen n nazca
instead of weirder and JC productions go
check it out oh yeah that's what yeah
NGC productions yeah all right see ya
and Tyler Hague thank you again buddy
can't wait to rub your nipples love you